The idea of shipping started in 3rd century BC,...
...when merchants realized that sending products over sea...
...was cheaper and faster than by land.
Early on, goods were loaded onto ships in sacks, barrels and wooden crates...
...with scores of dockworkers squeezing them on decks...
...or in tight spaces below.
Ships often spent more time at ports than sailing.
And not much changed until 1956.
That's when American truck driver Malcolm McLane...
...stacked 58 metal boxes on a ship going from New Jersey to Houston.
This idea completely revolutionized the industry.
The containers not only protected the products,...
...but when the ships docked at ports,...
...truck beds and freight trains could take them away without repackaging.
Cargo could now be moved from purpose-built vessels...
...to rail and roads in massive volumes,...
...cutting transport cost by at least 75 percent.